Let's continue along this vein of symmetry of parabolas. Now when we were
talking about linear equations, a super vital part of everything that we talked
was the slope of a line. And we can find the slope of a line by taking any two
points along it and taking the ratio of the difference between their y
coordinates to the difference between their x coordinate. We haven't however
considered this slope of a curve yet of a graph of anything that isn't just a
straight line. This may seem a little bit funny to think about but I think its
pretty important. There is a single sub that applies to every single point along
this curve. But we can talk about slope any local sense. Its pretty easy to see
what the slope of a single part of the curve is by picking a point on the line,
let's say this one and drawing a line that just touches the curve at that point
and has the same slope as the curve does right there. So for every point on a
curve we can say that there is a line tangent to that point, that has the same
slope as the curve at that point and barely touches the curve right there. So
it's actually really hard to draw an exact tangent line, but this is a pretty
good approximation. We pick two points that are infinitesimally far away from
this point or in other words two points that are as close as we can possibly
pick, to this point that we're interested in. We can draw the line connecting
those two points and then extend that line, tend up with the tangent line. Now
you have to wait for calculus to get a really deep and rigorous understanding of
tangent lines, but they're still really useful for us for understanding the
shapes of parabolas and of other curves as well. So now I've drawn 3 different
lines that are tangent to 3 different points on this parabola. I've labelled
them A, B and C and for each of those, I'd like you to tell me what the sign of
the slope of the line is. Is it positive, negative, or 0? Check the proper box
for each line.